hay un país que siempre siempre siempre
aparece en los grandes titulares de la
actualidad internacional
fundamentalmente por dos motivos el
fútbol y las crisis económicas el
problema amigos es que los titulares
cada vez están más vinculados a las
crisis que al fútbol hablo como no de
argentina
[Música]
es duro decirlo pero creo que todos
estaremos más o menos de acuerdo
argentina es un país que parece alérgico
a las reformas y adicto a las crisis y
es que cuando todo parecía empezar a
marchar bien 2018 se ha complicado mucho
tanto que el gobierno de mauricio macri
se ha visto obligado a pedir un rescate
al fondo monetario internacional a ver a
ver un momento rescate en argentina otra
vez pues queridos amigos de visual
político tal cual como lo escucháis
argentina el país de la pampa el tango y
los asados vuelve a estar contra las
cuerdas atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
abril y mayo de 2018 no han sido
precisamente dos meses buenos para
argentina
[Música]
[Aplausos]
invierno
las condiciones mundiales están cada día
más complejas y por varios factores
están subiendo las tasas de interés está
subiendo el petróleo se han devaluado
las monedas de países emergentes
unas semanas el peso si ha llegado a
depreciar un 20 por ciento pasando de
intercambiarse un dólar por 20 pesos a
un dólar por 25 pesos pero sabéis que no
ha sido una excepción desde que arrancó
2018 el peso se ha depreciado un 25 por
ciento
[Música]
y si ampliamos el horizonte temporal a
los últimos cinco años os hago una
pregunta sabría es decirme cuánto se ha
depreciado cuánto se ha hundido el peso
argentino pues ni más ni menos que un 80
por ciento brutal
[Música]
ahora bien no nos engañemos la caída del
tipo de cambio no es en sí mismo el
problema sino la consecuencia veréis
amigos el verdadero problema la
auténtica enfermedad de argentina es su
enorme adicción al gasto público y no no
estoy hablando de que el gasto público
sea más o menos alto de lo que sería
conveniente o de lo que nos gustaría
sino de un gasto público tan grande que
argentina simplemente no se lo puede
permitir en los últimos 57 años llevamos
53 con el estado gastando más de lo que
recauda es decir con déficit fiscal
durante esos 53 años tuvimos cuatro
crisis tremendas ahora estamos peleando
para que no ocurra la quinta josé luis
espert economista y autor del libro la
argentina devorada pero un momento
porque creo que ya sé lo que estáis
pensando alberto quien día antes tiene
que ver el gasto público con la
depreciación del peso pues mucho más de
lo que parece pero vayamos paso
[Música]
argentína amigo se enfrenta a una triple
bomba de relojería tiene un enorme
déficit exterior un enorme déficit
público y 250 mil millones de dólares de
deuda externa y como os podéis imaginar
los déficit y la deuda hay que pagarlos
y aquí es donde aparece otro gran
problema años y años de proteccionismo
devaluaciones hiperregulación e
impuestos altísimos porque ojo argentina
es uno de los países con los impuestos a
las empresas más altos de todo el
planeta todo ello ha hecho que la
industria y en general la economía
argentina no sean competitivas y también
que los capitales se fugaron hace ya
muchísimo tiempo del país en busca de
refugio
parece lógico verdad pues bien el
resultado como no hay plata en casa
argentina es muy dependiente de la
financiación extranjera fijaos según el
instituto de finanzas internacionales la
mayor parte casi el 64% de la deuda
estatal y de la deuda corporativa de
argentina está denominada en dólares y
otras divisas extranjeras
por eso tanto el volumen de reservas
extranjeras del banco central como el
tipo de cambio son muy pero que muy
importantes por un lado se necesitan
reservas para poder pagar las
importaciones y hacer frente a los pagos
de la deuda pero como argentina tiene un
saldo exterior negativo es decir consume
más dólares de los que obtiene necesita
que alguien le preste esos dólares que
los inversores lleven divisas al país y
amigos si lo hacen porque no se fían
argentina tiene un problema que digo un
problema un problemón por otro lado si
el peso se deprecia pues evidentemente
eso quiere decir que pierde valor y
amigos seamos honestos nadie quiere
tener sus ahorros en una moneda que
pierde valor tan rápido
[Música]
así que qué es lo que haces pues tratas
de cambiar corriendo todos tus pesos por
una divisa más fuerte más estable lo que
provoca que el peso se desplome aún más
y que las reservas se consuman todavía
más rápido pero vale dicho esto echemos
un vistazo al gobierno
[Música]
veréis tanto néstor kirchner como sobre
todo a cristina fernández de kirchner
les gustaba gastar gastar a manos llenas
cuando llegaron al poder en 2002 el
gasto público equivalía al 23 por ciento
del pib cuando lo dejaron a más del 40
por ciento pero seguro que os estáis
preguntando y qué hicieron con todo ese
dinero pues básicamente contratar
empleados públicos por eso de ganar
votos ya sabéis y multiplicar las
subvenciones
de esta forma por ejemplo en tan solo 13
años el empleo público se disparó un 60
por ciento para que os hagáis una idea
de la salvajada que supone hoy el 35 por
ciento de los empleados argentinos
trabajan para el gobierno
[Música]
pero a poco de conocer los países con
más desarrollo económico y social e
indagar en las claves de su crecimiento
y su desarrollo uno puede encontrar en
la defensa irrestricta de sus propios
intereses como estados y sociedades la
clave de ese avance la clave de ese
desarrollo
[Música]
incluso en siete provincias ojo hay más
trabajadores públicos que privados una
locura
[Música]
y por supuesto amigos como el gobierno
no tenía tanta plata para pagar todo
este dispendio pues año tras año
registraba un déficit público enorme sin
embargo lo sabéis los kirchner no podían
acudir a los mercados internacionales
primero porque los inversores no se
fiaban de ellos y segundo porque el país
había incurrido en default
[Música]
default fue el año 2001 cuando se dejó
de pagar la deuda y además se anunció
pero no se embargaron el tango 01 nos
embargaron nos intentaron embargar la
embajada argentina en eeuu nos
intentaron embargar el satélite gsat nos
intentaron embargar satélites de la
conae
y claro si no pagas pues evidentemente
no te vuelven a prestar ni un céntimo
así que qué crees que hicieron exacto
utilizar la máquina favorita de todos
los políticos populistas darle a la
máquina de imprimir billetes y pagar el
gasto público con nuevos pesos
eso y establecer un cepo cambiario o sea
limitar la cantidad de dinero que los
argentinos podían sacar del país para
que no se comieran las menguantes
reservas
[Música]
y la pregunta es qué ocurre cuando se
siguen estas políticas pues que la
inflación se dispara por los nuevos
pesos que hay en circulación y los
inversores extranjeros desde luego no
quieren saber absolutamente nada de ti y
así en estas circunstancias es como
mauricio macri llegó al poder
[Música]
el plan de macri
amigos cuando mauricio macri llegó a la
casa rosada- tenía un plan aplicar
reformas poco a poco es lo que se ha
conocido como el gradualismo para esto
implementamos una política económica
gradualista que busca equilibrar el
desastre que nos dejaron en nuestras
cuentas públicas cuidando los sectores
vulnerables y al mismo tiempo creciendo
creando así más empleo y desarrollo y lo
cierto es que se han hecho bastantes
cosas bien se ha mejorado el clima para
hacer negocios se han reducido algunas
subvenciones y en cierto modo se
recuperó la confianza de los inversores
internacionales
[Música]
pero de todo lo difícil que había que
hacer ha hecho solo lo más fácil lo que
no ha logrado en estos más de dos años
de gobierno ha sido reducir el déficit
público ni la inflación
claro a pesar de volver a tener acceso a
los mercados financieros el gobierno
argentino ha continuado dándole a la
máquina de imprimir billetes para
mantener el enorme gasto público y eso
supone necesariamente más inflación
fijaos en este gráfico podemos ver cómo
está creciendo la cantidad de dinero es
decir como el banco central de la
república de argentina sigue emitiendo
más y más pesos
[Música]
pero vale puede que os estéis
preguntando pero no se suponía que macri
llegaba para cambiar las cosas pues sí
pero con matices veréis todo esto tiene
una explicación la idea que tenía el
equipo del presidente macri era llevar a
cabo poco a poco reformas que trajeran
inversiones que hicieran crecer a la
economía argentina si la economía crecía
pues el gobierno recaudaría más y no
tendría que hacer recortes
[Música]
mientras tanto poco a poco como estaban
recuperando la confianza de los mercados
internacionales pues podrían emitir
deuda y así poder reducir la necesidad
de darle a la máquina de imprimir
billetes de esta forma en pocos años
argentina se libraría del déficit la
inflación y volvería a crecer imagen y
por supuesto mantendría su capital
político intacto para continuar ganando
elecciones suena bien verdad
[Música]
bueno el caso es que hasta ahora más o
menos las cosas han ido como estaba
previsto sin embargo amigos esperad un
momento porque ahora eso ha cambiado
principalmente por dos motivos
[Música]
primero tras dos años y medio en el
poder es difícil entender cómo el
déficit público la inflación y los
impuestos siguen por las nubes el
gradualismo se ha convertido en algo así
como la carrera de una tortuga con reuma
y segundo porque la reserva federal de
eeuu ha comenzado a subir los tipos de
interés veréis hoy la deuda pública de
eeuu el bono a 10 años está rindiendo ya
al 3%
[Música]
y claro muchos inversores se hacen ahora
esta pregunta si la deuda de eeuu que
supuestamente es el activo con menos
riesgo
me da una rentabilidad razonable por qué
diantres me voy a arriesgar prestando mi
dinero a la argentina donde no veo
cambios
[Música]
pues esto es precisamente lo que ha
provocado que muchos capitales que
habían comenzado a llegar ahora se estén
dando la vuelta
y por esto el gobierno de macri ha
decidido recurrir al fondo monetario
internacional para obtener una línea de
crédito con la que hacer frente a los
vencimientos de deuda de los próximos
meses y del próximo año no sea que los
inversores ya no quieran poner más plata
sobre la mesa
tenéis como sería un default antes de
las elecciones de 2019 veis todo tiene
que ver con el comportamiento del
gobierno y si lo pensáis un momento es
muy sensato simplemente la paciencia se
ha terminado lo que dicen los inversores
y los propios ahorradores argentinos es
muy bien si quieres gastar por encima de
tus posibilidades
'allá tú' pero no va a ser con mi dinero
i
y no solo el gasto público también otras
muchas reformas que hagan más fácil
hacer negocios y esto nos lleva a una
pregunta clave ha llegado la hora de
abandonar el gradualismo
[Música]
terapias agresivas o gradualismo
amigos hacer reformas nunca es fácil
pero creo que ha llegado la hora de que
en la casa rosada se hagan una pregunta
no será el momento de aplicar medidas
más agresivas pues sabéis que se me
ocurre que podemos echar un vistazo a la
evidencia histórica que pensáis que ha
funcionado mejor el gradualismo o la
terapia agresiva
un buen ejemplo de grandes
transformaciones lo tenemos en los
antiguos países de la órbita soviética
cuando en 1989 el modelo comunista se
desplomó hubo países que aplicaron
cambios drásticos casi de la noche a la
mañana y otros que en cambio apostaron
por medidas más graduales
sabéis quienes han tenido desde entonces
mejores resultados pues si los primeros
los que más reformas hicieron de golpes
países como estonia letonia lituania
polonia o la república checa fueron los
que más apostaron por la terapia del
golpe es decir por hacer reformas lo más
rápido posible
y si al principio fue duro pero
enseguida comenzaron a crecer y a lograr
todo tipo de inversiones hasta tal punto
que hoy estos países casi todos muy
pobres en 1989 tienen ya un nivel de
vida superior a portugal oa cualquier
país latinoamericano
en cambio entre los que aplicaron
reformas graduales bueno encontramos a
países como ucrania rumanía tayikistán o
armenia a los cuales digamos las cosas
no les han ido tan bien ni en términos
económicos ni en términos sociales
en fin amigos esta es la decisión que
tiene que tomar el gobierno de macri a
aprovechar o no el dinero del fmi para
llevar a cabo de una vez por todas
reformas de peso y seamos claros si
argentina no corrige el déficit público
y no deja de darle a la máquina de
imprimir billetes el futuro no pinta
nada pero que nada bien pedir plata
prestada no es gobernar bien gobernar
bien es hacer las reformas de fondo en
argentina y en estado elefantiásico
gigantesco hipertrofiado que hay que
adelgazar hay que recortar los gastos
públicos
jaime bayly además es que el modelo
simplemente no funciona el gobierno
argentino nunca había gastado tanto y a
pesar de ello hacía décadas que no había
tanta pobreza y tanta violencia
[Música]
habrá macri tomado no está solo el
futuro podrá respondernos a esta
pregunta pero ahora a turno para ti qué
piensas apuestas por seguir con las
reformas graduales o crees que ha
llegado la hora de un proceso de cambio
más rápido déjanos tu respuesta como
siempre en los comentarios y también en
esta encuesta amigos sé que es un tema
denso pero espero que hayamos podido
verter un poquito de luz si ha sido así
dale a like y comparte el vídeo con tus
amigos un abrazo y hasta la próxima
por cierto activa la campanita si
quieres que youtube te avise de nuevos
vídeos de visual política hasta luego
[Música]